It shouldn't really be news to anyone that a lot of our favorite movies have alternate endings that didn't quite make the cut.
The reasons for these decisions are varied.
But it turns out that a lot of the time it comes down to the fact that the original ending that the director had planned
Was just too dark for general audiences. For this video
we're taking a look at some darker movie endings that ended up getting cut. Let us know what you think of these endings and be
sure to subscribe to ScreenRant to stay up to date with all our new videos
Before we start, can you name this movie by looking at these emojis?
Hang on to your answer until the end. Here are 10 movie endings that would have been too dark for viewers.
"It's a cold sore never had one before, so, uh, started to cry"
Pineapple Express
When you think of great Seth Rogen comedies,
2008's Pineapple Express probably isn't the first one that comes to mind. The movie is hilarious, but truthfully
it's forgettable and doesn't hold up to some of Rogan's better films. However, Pineapple Express may have been much more
memorable if the filmmakers had stuck with the original
ending that they had planned; as it stands the movie ends with Seth Rogen and James Franco
surviving the big shootout and
Recapping the whole thing over some breakfast. In the original
script, however, Rogen and Franco were going to stay in the warehouse get high and then ends up getting shot by a remaining bad guy
that they had forgotten about. It's a much darker way to end things
but who knows it may have made this comedy a little more memorable
"You're wrong. Soon i'll be dead, and you with me."
Star Wars episode six return of the Jedi
"Don't mess with the original trilogy" screamed every Star Wars fan watching this video. Alright, alright,
we won't but Producer Gary Kurtz
nearly did, as the first version of the script for episode five actually included the death of a major character.
Kurtz actually wanted to kill off Han Solo in the movie during a raid on the imperial base.
But George Lucas shut down this idea according to Kurt, Lucas liked the idea
but he was worried that it would hurt the sales of Star Wars merchandise
so he opted to keep Han Solo alive and well. Kurtz was pissed and ended up severing ties with George Lucas over this dispute.
We have to wonder what his reaction was like when he saw Han Solo killed in 2015's The Force Awakens
Do you think he was happy to see the character finally offed? or was he upset
that lucas snatched his idea and used it many years later?
American Sniper
American Sniper is one of the more
divisive movies to come out in recent years as fans are split on how they feel about Clint Eastwood's
interpretation of Chris Kyle's Story. The movie definitely isn't a comedy,
but it turns out that it was almost a hell of a lot darker than it ended up being. In the original
script the movie was going to show Bradley cooper actually taking a bullet at the shooting range,
but when Chris Kyle's actual widow called and asked to keep that moment out, the filmmakers obliged. She told the creators that this movie would
be how her children remembered their father and that they had to get it right, so
Eastwood opted to fade to black as cooper headed off to the shooting range.
The movie has definitely taken some heat for some of the things it showed
But we have to give it kudos for making this decision.
"Nah, he used to look up in the sky and wonder
at our place in the stars."
Interstellar
After winning over the entire world with his Batman trilogy,
Christopher Nolan divided the world with his confusing but impressive film Interstellar.
Wherever you stand on the film as a whole, you have to acknowledge that there are a lot of good things in there and that
the ending is pretty cool and uplifting. Well, if writer Jonathan Nolan had gotten his way we would have seen a much different, much bleaker
ending. Fans got to see
McConaughey's coups succeed in sending messages back from the fifth dimension to help save humanity
But Jonathan Nolan's original crips had pooped dying when he entered the black hole Christopher is the director
So he had final stage and decided to go with the happier and more inspirational conclusion. "We just let the snowman be."
"Great. Well oh come on!
Disney Struck gold with
2013's frozen and we're guessing that they would like us to believe that everything we know and love about the movie was planned right from
the Get-go. Well that definitely isn't the case as
Frozen was almost a very different movie and Anna and Elsa were almost very different characters from the ones that fans now adore. The original
Script featured a much darker version of Elsa where she was actually slated to be the villain of the film. On top of that
Kristen Bell who voices Anna in the film revealed that her character nearly had a much more reductive and prissy princess role.
Apparently after an entire year of working on frozen these characters were reworked to be the more fun and full princesses
We got to see the creators definitely made the right call as frozen has reached incredible levels of success.
"You said on our very first date that you don't like flowers if they're a waste of money"
"Every girl likes flowers, Gary." The break-up
Vince vaughn and Jennifer Aniston did a great job of showcasing the trials and tribulations of a serious split in their
2006 comedy the break-up.
But it turns out that the ending was almost quite different. The movie the public got to see wrapped up with a nice scene showing
exes vaughn and Aniston randomly running into each other on the streets and sharing a pleasant moment.
The original Script didn't have this scene at all and the movie just ended with the two characters parting ways. The producers decided to add
The final scene because at the time
Aniston was going through a very public breakup with Brad Pitt in real life
and they didn't want it to seem like they were just telling her real world story they decided to add in the final scene to
Add some hope to the movie instead of ending on a grim note clerks clerks
Is one of the most beloved cult movies of all time and it's one of the only
reasons that everyone still put up with Kevin Smith's
Ridiculousness the movie does a great job of finding interesting
Moments in a mundane world and the ending the fans got to see seems to fit that mold
dante closes up shop
And then spend some time thinking about how he ended working as a clerk in a quick stop
However clerks almost wrapped up in a much more dramatic way as the original ending was much much darker
Kevin Smith actually filmed a different ending where the movie concludes with dante getting gunned down
By a burglar this would have left audiences with a very different taste in their mouth and we have to wonder if the film would
Have achieved as much success as it
Did what do you think do you like the ending the way it is or would you have gone [to] the darker routes?
If you can dodge a wrench, you can dodge a ball nice
Dodge ball one of the greatest underdog stories of all time
Dodgeball is a
Must-see for anyone who likes to laugh and enjoy?
Seeing the little guy triumph over the villain the movie ends with Vince vaughn's team of misted feeding ben stiller squad of mutants and everyone
Gets to feel good about themselves however
It almost didn't go that way as the original ending sauce [fillers] globo gym winning the tournament this ending apparently tested terribly
Everywhere except for Russia weirdly enough so the filmmakers decided to go [back] and reshoot a new ending that would leave audiences with a good
Feeling it might be a bit cliched, but sometimes it's nice [to] see the cinderella story completed clark
yre National Lampoon's vacation
one of the great comedy classics of all time the Chedi Chase
Led Family Comedy National Lampoon's vacation is jam-packed with ridiculous moments that are still funny today [chase] is
Amazing in the movie and his over-the-top
Character is so adamant about getting his family to Walley world that he actually seems somewhat insane. That's probably why?
Director Howald [ramos] actually shot another ending to the film that was much darker the alternate ending featured chases clark bringing his family to
Wally's home and forcing the creator of the part to entertain his family at Wally world at gunpoint
This dark ending tested Terribly with audiences
So it was dropped
But it honestly makes quite a bit of sense when you consider how insane clark Griswold really? Is that was a pretty good plan?
guardians of the Galaxy
Praised as being one of the most fun movies in the entire McU it's somewhat surprising to find out that guardians of the Galaxy
almost featured a darker and more emotional ending the movie concludes with fun scenes all
Main characters set to the classic song ain't no mountain high enough the montage is a hoot
but it almost included a few other characters that would have totally shifted the tone originally director James gunn wanted to check in with
Nebula and the Collector, but he decided against it in the end
That's not all though gun also revealed that there was originally going to be a very somber moment showing Peter quills grandfather
Reflecting on the abduction of his grandson while this would have been a nice character building moment
It totally would have killed the vibe of the happy ending. So it makes sense. Why they decided to leave it out
Well there you have it folks
There's our look at 10 movies that almost gave us much much darker ending would you have preferred any of these darker?
Conclusions let us know what you think down below and before [you] take off the go make a super dark Indie thriller
Make [sure] you subscribe to screen man and join the notification squad. Thanks for watching